-Multiple co-defendants
in one of Donald Trump's
criminal cases
have now flipped on him
by pleading guilty
and agreeing
to testify against him,
including his former lawyer,
Sidney Powell,
who Trump is now claiming
was never actually his lawyer,
despite the fact
that he said at the time
Sidney Powell was his lawyer.
For more on this,
it's time for A Closer Look.
[ Cheers and applause ]
As horrifying as it may be,
the reality is that Donald Trump
is currently the far
and away front runner
for the GOP nomination
for president in 2024.
What does far and away mean?
Well, he's ahead by roughly
21 points
in the current FiveThirtyEight
polling average against
every other candidate combined.
If you Voltron the GOP field
into one super candidate,
it would not be within shouting
distance of Donald Trump,
a man with the largest
shouting radius in America.
What's that?
If you Voltron the GOP field,
what body parts would you
take from each candidate?
It's obvious.
Mike Pence's "I'm concerned,
but not enough to do anything"
face,
Ron DeSantis'
pudding-scooping fingers,
and Doug Burgum's
glass eye.
Did you know Doug Burgum
has a glass eye?
He doesn't, but I didn't
know anything about him,
so I made it up.
Before today,
I didn't even know he was
the governor of South Dakota,
which is okay, because he's
the governor of North Dakota.
But Trump, the biggest front
runner who has ever run front,
has just been hit
with more bad legal news.
Another one of his co-defendants
just flipped on him.
-In a surprise move,
former Trump attorney
Kenneth Chesebro pled guilty
to a felony in the Georgia
election interference case
and accepted a plea deal
with prosecutors.
The Harvard-educated lawyer
has seen quite a fall
in the last few years.
Considered the legal architect
of the plan
to use fake electors
to steal the election,
Chesebro now faces 100 hours
of community service,
five years probation,
a $5,000 fine,
and perhaps most importantly,
he will testify against
the other co-defendants,
including Donald Trump.
-You know how I know
this is bad for Trump?
I don't remember
who this guy is.
When I first saw his photo,
I thought it was
Montana Governor Doug Burgum.
Because you see, when nutballs
like Rudy Giuliani
and Mike Lindell
get in trouble,
it just feels like
that's part of the plan.
It's been factored in.
But when an anonymous white
collar Harvard guy goes down
and says he'll cooperate
with prosecutors,
that's got to be when Trump is
thinking to himself, "Oh, no."
Because if Mike Lindell
or Rudy Giuliani
ever flipped on Trump
and told a jury
Trump was guilty,
Trump would be found innocent
by the first lunch break,
because they're [bleep] nuts.
I kind of think that was
the whole game plan.
Let those two hair-dye-addicted
clowns scream
and cry on TV while the quiet,
buttoned up
Harvard guy does all
the real crying for you.
But these buttoned up
quiet type --
the Chesebros, if you will --
are the ones who actually
understand what went down.
He's a Harvard-educated lawyer
with a long history
in Washington politics,
who might actually be able
to explain to a jury
where the bodies are buried,
as opposed to Rudy,
who looks like a guy who knows
the best places to dig one up.
[As Giuliani] "I look for
tombstones with fancy names.
They're most likely
to be wearing watches."
[Normally] Before we move on,
a lot of time was spent today
on making a joke
about how Chesebro
sounds like a line of
cheese-based Hasbro products.
But it was decided that had
nothing to do
with this very important news
story, so we abandoned that.
We didn't want to waste
your time by showing you
what products they would make.
Products like Barbrie.
Or My Little Provolony.
We're better than that.
And more importantly,
you're better than that.
And this plea deal came one day
after another plea deal
that was bad for Trump.
Last week, we told you that
former Trump lawyer
Sidney Powell
pleaded guilty and agreed
to cooperate with prosecutors
in their investigation
of Trump's attempt to overturn
the 2020 election
results in Georgia.
You might recall Powell
from this recent mugshot,
where she looks like she just
saw the videotape from the ring
and she was on it.
[As Powell] "Hello. Seven days?
All right. I'll see you then."
Telemarketers.
[Normally]
Or you might also remember
Powell from her star turn
as one of the key witnesses
in the January 6th hearing,
where she was asked about
her conversations
with President Trump
in the run up
to the coup attempt.
-In fact, you did
Get to see the president
without an appointment.
-We did.
-In the short period of time
that you had with the president,
did he seem receptive
to the presentation
that you were making?
[ Laughter ]
-God bless the video editor
who decided to leave
in that long beat of Powell
downing her Diet Dr. Pepper.
Nothing tells you that a person
is out of the mind
faster than seeing them
chug a Diet Dr. Pepper.
I don't even know where to find
Diet Dr. Pepper.
I think you have to buy
a soda machine
from an antiques dealer and pry
the back off with a crowbar.
You know, when that tape
first surfaced,
we had our fun
making jokes about
Diet Dr. Pepper
being a terrible soda.
But I never tried it.
And I want to let everyone know
that since then, I had one.
One.
Now, just as
a reminder of her role
in the attempt
to overturn the election,
here's a quick recap
of some of the crazy [bleep]
she was saying at the time
as a member of Donald Trump's
legal team.
-It's been organized
and conducted
with the help
of Silicon Valley people,
the big tech companies,
the social media companies,
and even the media companies.
What we are really
dealing with here
and uncovering more
by the day,
is the massive influence
of communist money
through Venezuela,
Cuba, and likely China
in the interference
with our elections here
in the United States.
-[As Powell] In fact, we can
prove Cuba and Venezuela
were involved in the election
because their signs
were everywhere.
[ Laughter ]
Rudy, can you wipe
your face quieter?
[Normally] I guess the better
question for Powell
would have been who wasn't
involved in the conspiracy
to steal the election.
[As Powell] Big tech companies,
social media companies,
home furnishing companies,
all the major sports leagues,
the airlines, every steakhouse
in New York City,
Chili's, both the country,
the restaurant,
and the temperature,
and all the major soda brands,
excluding Diet Dr. Pepper,
because no one
in their right mind
would consider
that monstrosity a soda.
[Normally] In that same
interview
with the January
6th Committee,
Powell also confirmed
that Trump at one point
tried to appoint her
special counsel
to investigate
the 2020 election.
-On Friday, he had asked me
to be special counsel
to address the election issues.
-Can you imagine this lunatic
with security clearance?
I wouldn't clear her
for a Costco card.
Oh, that's where she gets
the Diet Dr. Pepper.
[As Powell] I buy it
by the pallet.
[Normally] Anyway,
last week we found out
that Powell had pleaded guilty
in the criminal case
over Trump's attempt to overturn
the election results in Georgia.
And then on Sunday,
Trump claimed
he actually has nothing to do
with Sidney Powell.
-Trump is responding
to two of his allies
who flipped on him,
taking plea deals
in the Georgia election
interference case.
Trump tried to distance himself
from campaign lawyer
Sidney Powell,
writing on Truth Social,
"Ms. Powell was not my attorney
and never was."
-[As Trump] And another thing,
I don't know
who the hell
this Melania lady is.
She was not and has
never been my wife.
I mean, just look at us.
Do we look like a couple?
Talk about chillies.
[Normally] Obviously.
They're -- [ Laughs ]
I mean, not -- not today,
but years from now,
they'll look back and be like,
"Oh, that was good."
Obviously, there are a couple
of problems with this claim.
First of all,
as we just told you,
Powell and others confirmed
and sworn testimony
that she was in
the Oval Office with Trump,
where he tried to name
her special counsel
with security clearance to
investigate the 2020 election.
Second, at that infamous
press conference,
Rudy told
the assembled media
that Powell was part
of Trump's legal team.
-Thank you very much for coming.
This is a representative
of our legal team.
We're representing
President Trump
and we're representing
the Trump campaign.
When I finish, Sidney Powell
and then --
and then Jenna Ellis
will follow me.
-Trump's only defense here
is that Rudy Giuliani
is untrustworthy,
which is true.
But then that applies
to everything,
including the election
fraud claims.
You can't have it both ways.
[As Trump] That Rudy guy is out
of his [bleep] mind.
You can't trust a word he says.
Except on China and Hugo Chavez
teaming up with Dominion
and Big Tech
to steal the election.
It's weird because on that,
he's right on the money.
Usually crazy.
[Normally] And then, of course,
there's one more small problem
with Trump's claim that Powell
was never his attorney.
In November of 2020, Trump said
that Powell was his attorney.
-The president wrote...
-It's like Ocean's 11
if they were trying to give
$160 million to a casino.
[As Powell] Okay, Rudy, let's go
over the plan one more time.
Blackjack?
[As Giuliani] Always hit on 20.
[As Powell] Roulette?
[As Giuliani] Put it all
on yellow.
[As Powell] Craps?
[As Giuliani] Eat the dice.
[Normally] Fun fact --
most of that legal team
has now been indicted.
If you did
a where are they now,
the answer for almost all of
them would be facing charges,
except for Joseph diGenova,
who would be,
from the looks of him, getting
thrown off a JetBlue flight
for trying to sneak in
his own marinara sauce.
DiGenova used to be one of our
favorite Trump side characters
because he looks
like the uncle
who complains about the portions
at a Staten Island wedding.
"You know, for the price
this thing costs,
you think they wouldn't
skimp on the prosciutto?"
But hey,
maybe I'm not Joey diGenova.
But he's not really around
anymore,
which is good for the world,
but sad for us.
But you know,
when I miss him,
I can always just put on
an old episode of "NYPD Blue."
Here's one more piece
of evidence
that Powell has a direct
connection to Trump
and his attempts
to overturn the election --
she said it herself
in an interview
with an Australian news program
two years ago.
-How did you come to be involved
in the election effort,
post the election?
-I wish I knew. [ Laughs ]
It was like this huge tsunami
hit us.
I was in the area at the time.
I had worked with Mr. Giuliani
for a few days
before on another matter,
and the next thing I know,
I'm smack in the middle of it.
-Did you already have
a relationship
with President Trump?
-Yes, I did have a relationship
with President Trump.
-What was your relationship
with Trump? Did he trust you?
-I believe he did trust me.
-And had you been much
in the Oval Office?
-Yes, I'd been there
a number of times.
-I like how she was
just in the area
and then ended up
in the Oval Office
with the president
of the United States,
like she broke off from
her tour group to answer a text.
"Hey, has anyone
seen Aunt Sidney?"
"Yeah, she was pulled away by
a gnome whose head was leaking."
"Should we tell the police?"
"No?"
Trump thinks that just because
he never pays his lawyers,
that means they weren't
his lawyers,
but sadly, they were.
They were his accomplices,
with direct knowledge
of his criminal scheme
to dismantle American democracy.
And now, they've pleaded guilty
and agreed to cooperate
with prosecutors.
It doesn't matter
if they're Harvard educated,
white collar lawyers
or weirdos who drink
Diet Dr. Pepper, not by the can,
but by the tsunami.
This has been A Closer Look.